これよく見ると思います文をしアンサーを[ __ ]殺虫のパキがピンポーンってますね
これめっちゃよく見ると思うし youtube でもよく使われるんですけどもう
クイズラリーとかでもこう
問題が出て来てる時にいいっ
てると思うんですけどもっとねぇこれ
電池で打っで
ああああああ
これは薄てさあ音が重くねなんか
ああ
ええっはてなマーク出てますけど自信ないのかな
パッ幸田コーナー2感じで赤いほどはコピッポンなレスがあるんですけども
もし
大切な場面で壊れたらどうせますか大雪の時にをそんな方だなかったらその一瞬が
台無しになってしまうそんなことあっていいのでしょうか
ダメなんですよそうなんですわけで今回はこのピンポンが何回目で壊れるか実験して
いきたいとおもいます
いや本当に綺麗になる頃のばっぱのば姉が壊れる買った課題段階から使ったら電池で
なくなるのかなとか遅くのボタンも
の優しくをそしてネスの子じゃぐらいのなんか艶紅をふと見ると思うんでこれ自体の
まあ電池メンのこの羽根面ボタン年いろんな面においてどれだけ使うとどこか対処に
壊れだすのカオスと検証していきたいとおもいます
今鼻で笑ったの学校よっていきますん
1回目ん
[拍手]
はぁ
[音楽]
ああああああ
楽静岡帰れなくなりますや俺が競ってこうしてからいてで100回行きましたがまぁ
ちょっとまだですねまだ全然元気そうと思いますどんどん行きましょう
[音楽]
ていていた
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[拍手]
おっん
[音楽]
はいそういうわけで500回行きました
見た目的に全然真の問題はないんですけど音がちょっとねぇ
なんでもないですもうちょい頑張ってみましょう
[音楽]
いってっチェーン
範囲というわけで1000回行きました
ございます
これやっぱいなーん前回でも全然壊れている様子はありませんねさあここからが私が
絶叫していきますはせませんボタンをだけでとてもつまらない動画になっております
さあてが早いてが早い夫
物資しているてが物資している
いたそうですねサードっていきますショーをするブレッド黒飲みながらやっていくうち
が早いすごいてが無視してる
妙これ書いておけや4つ見せずに破っついて画文集ているに見えていますがこれは早く
いませんですごいですねでもエールあたって何体目で a 解禁ボタンはおられるの
でしょうか
前で遊んの poke ってが扮してるすごい
いる卓球から卓球をしているのかお前ら2月のでまさにポンダー
提言に旋回いきましたーーー
2000回いってば大きな変化といえば
ないっすねー台東区でに1000回超えてきただけで正直言いましょう
とてもしんどくなってきましたがなーん
頑張ってるからもうちょっと見てくれよああ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
3事務そうな2にもうすぐ3全開だ
3000回に1スター
阿部しないぜまだまだ行くぜさあさん前回からの大台でございますてこんな所に伸びる
のか
おっとなりとも顔の競争が硬いぞ無機質な共同になっていますが
では取れない際レンガをしているが誰の顔は全く面白そうではありません
どんどん数字を伸ばしてやがて4戦になるか
[音楽]
これはやっていて楽しいのか
今どこれるんだよ桜と言ってはいけないことを言ってしまった最後の予選でキャンセル
なぁ
この枠はついに5000回というわけでございますがもうほたんの叩き方が完全にプロ
となっちゃいますね
あのこの両店資料球児がすごい速い交互に打って背が痛いようですが
こっちみんなという感じですが汗は早いさあ5000回たーーー
さあ
5000回きましたーー
これ壊れないんじゃねぇみたいな空気が漂っているんですけどもまぁとりあえずあ
[拍手]
さあ亮典世が止まらないこの武器はまるで論キーコンがゲームゲームの外ドンキー
こんなのようだ
あと目が通いたちも目がかゆいさあ8000後半でございますやがて9000台になり
ますがそうだ2人の胸像は
一つも嬉しそうではない
さあこのままどんどんたたえていくと2時はついに9999カンストしてしまう
果たしてん
彼らを待ち受けているのは a 交換それどう
地獄だーっ
1990ゲー
一番
はぁ
me
バッハ
これ競っても意味がないですよね9999回もクイズ大会することないもう一生ない本